[Music]
all right
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream 152 q and a segment
we are ready to uh to rock and also roll
yes we are so let's do that yeah
yeah God question that they most want to
see answered every week and that's how
we start our q a in those weeks that we
do q a q's in it
this week
um
we'll just read it I will say in advance
I don't uh
I've never heard this before
a doctor in New Zealand Dr Sam Bailey
challenges the very existence of viruses
in the entire field of virology
her main points one no viruses have been
proven to be transmissible from Human to
human two methodology and viral studies
doesn't follow the scientific method
three no controls were used for they
don't satisfy their own requirements
well you turned out
or something
nope
it's on
can you hear me now
okay are you able to you heard me though
hold on
how about now yeah yeah
okay uh should I read the question again
yeah this is the Discord question
take two
so from the Discord this week
we have the following question uh which
is on a topic that I have literally not
heard of before I have not heard this
this this take before
a doctor in New Zealand Dr Sam Bailey
challenges the very existence of viruses
in the entire field of virology her main
points are one no viruses have been
proven to be transmissible from Human to
human to methodology and viral studies
don't follow the scientific method three
no controls were used four they don't
satisfy their own requirements this
perspective seems credible but what do
you think
now I don't know have you heard of Dr
Sam Bailey uh I think I have run across
this and I have a kind of a flat Earth
Sense about it yeah and then excuse me I
think um you know it's not
it's not quite Flat Earth because uh
because individuals can assess the
veracity of Flat Earth themselves
without any special technological
anything
uh but
it at first at first glance which for me
this is it's what it feels like to me
but then it's also true that what we're
being given is a summary by someone else
of her main points and at least in
summary form
um
three of these are three of her three of
the Four Points as described are uh
unassailable isn't maybe the right
connotation but you can't respond to
them
methodology and viral studies doesn't
follow the scientific method
I am I feel like if I were given the
task of going out and finding virology
research that follows a scientific
method I would be able to find it I
don't know I've never explicitly tried
to do that but I find that to be a
blanket statement that is very unlikely
to be true
uh no controls were used
when for what question like well I don't
even know what what that means in this
context for they don't satisfy their own
requirements
again I don't know what that means don't
satisfy who's on requirements we don't
know how much of this is a reporting
problem in the question where they've
been as I said efficient in reporting
and how much of this has to do with the
research right
um and the first one no virus has been
proven to be transmissible from Human to
Human
I don't think that's true but I don't
know well there's a question about what
you know can you elevate the standard of
evidence so high that you can't meet it
yes right right
um
I will point out that the fact that no
virus has ever been proven to be
transmissible from Human to human even
if that's true does not say viruses
don't exist and in fact whether they
don't transmit from Human to human just
because we haven't proved something
doesn't mean it's not doesn't exist
right yeah
um and the fact is bacteriophages exist
right
um and coronaviruses exist too it
doesn't mean that they behave the way
they are claimed to but the point is if
the claim is they don't eat viruses
don't exist
then the question is well what's the
bacteriophage I've seen them
yeah right so anyway the point is
something here is off now I should go
back I did not mean to say it's strikes
me as Flat Earth in the sense that it is
equally easy to falsify I don't believe
that what I meant was Flat Earth is
something I don't spend time on
because it does not appear likely to be
a fruitful
uh use
right yeah um and there are other things
that I don't think are right as I've
mentioned you know I think the moon
landing happened I'm almost certain of
it right
um but going through the exercise of how
many of these claims are possible for me
to dismiss and discovering that actually
there's some claims here that are a
little troubling
um is useful it's not a waste of time
right and so the question is what is the
likelihood that this one is going to be
fruitful and if the claim is viruses
don't exist my sense is already
something yeah right no and I I mean
again this is
um this isn't a fair we aren't given a
fair ability to assess Dr Sam Bailey's
work by given by being given given a
summary of that work by someone who is
presumably not calling themselves a
virologist themselves so the
you know the question is given says
that Dr Bailey challenges the very
existence of viruses
the only one of the main points provided
that would seem to speak to that at all
is no viruses have been proven to be
transmissible from Human to human but
that already imagines that viruses exist
and maybe they just haven't been proven
to be transmissible so already we're at
odds with sort of the the fundamental
assumptions of of this so
I don't know I I really seriously doubt
it but I've never even seen this before
so I would uh as a cautionary tale I
would point out
that I have reversed course a couple
times on an issue that sounds like this
one and then turns out uh to have depth
to it so
um Carrie Mullis
um Nobel prize winning inventor of PCR
argued and he was not alone but he
argued that HIV did not cause AIDS and I
remember when I first read that thinking
I know exactly what error he's making
uh whatever did you think he was making
it was an over
uh an overly narrow instantiation of
what I think is called
Coke's postulate so coax postulate says
if a disease causes a pathology that
nobody who has the pathology or if a
pathogen
causes a pathology than nobody who has
the pathogen should not have the
pathology and nobody who's got the
pathology should lack the pathogen which
is nonsense at least the second I'm not
sure the first part of that is part of
the postulate but maybe I think it is
but
nonetheless the point is look if you do
that too narrowly here's the problem
that you miss
the human body and every other
animal is composed of a huge network of
interconnected pathways
you can disrupt the pathway and anything
Downstream on that pathway is disrupted
so it is very possible to get a bunch of
symptoms that are the result of the fact
that you've interfered with one coenzyme
or something that has disrupted
everything Downstream you can say well
here are 16 things that go along with
that pathology so the point is why
they're more than one thing that could
disrupt you know could have
congenital mutation Cause A disruption
of that coenzyme causing everything in
that Cascade to fail yeah could a
pathogen interfere with some stage of
production yeah so the point is there
could be multiple things that result in
the same set of symptoms and if you say
well X doesn't cause that set of
symptoms because here are some people
who don't have X and do have the
symptoms then you blew it
so I thought that was the error he was
making
it turns out that the argument against
hiv-causing AIDS is stronger than this
and that in fact the answer is not that
nobody's denying that HIV is a virus
that it is being transmitted but the
question is is it essentially a fellow
traveler not significantly harmful in
and of itself traveling with something
else that might be causing this
pathology or is it the causal agent in
and of itself yeah and anyway and
there's a if I if memory serves a long
chapter elucidating some of this
thinking and history in Bobby Kennedy's
yeah in the real Anthony yeah yep so
anyways I'm not telling you hard reading
but important I'm not telling you that
I've reached a firm conclusion but I'm
telling you I initially dismissed
mollusk because I thought he was a
chemist who was not appreciating the
complexity of biology
I now believe that the argument is a
more difficult one to dismiss because
the
you know how do you know when you are
looking at a pathogen that is
transmitted along with something else
that you haven't yet identified and when
it's the causal agent not as easy as you
would think so I leave open the
possibility that there is more to this
other claim than I understand but at the
moment my first instinct is
almost certainly not right and probably
not fruitful to pursue yep
all right questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com
[Music]
I chatted with a GPT a i today what's
GPT
I've forgotten what it stands for but
this is a um do you know Zach I have no
idea it's a protocol that uh is doing a
pretty good job of simulative passing
the Turing test during test okay yeah I
chatted with a Jeep
yes I chatted with a GPT AI today and
gave it a poem I wrote to evaluate
it reviewed the tone and message akin to
what I was taught in school
so much of society's decision making is
algorithm based so I asked if AI could
replace doctors it said AI couldn't
replace empathy and intuition
what does it mean to be human
well I too have interacted with this AI
I think the same one
um
I find some of the interaction uh so
robotic and pedantic as to be reassuring
and I found other elements of the
interaction a little bit shocking
um
what does it mean to be human I believe
that's one of those questions
that uh you could Chase your tail on
forever
it's not
yes we can come up with well I mean
there's there's an historical answer yep
right like what does it mean to be
a Fela silvestrius or Homo sapiens right
you know there's a phylogenetic answer
yep but there's there's nothing let's
put it this way let's take your
phylogenetic one and say that's going to
be the answer okay I'm not saying it's
the only obviously that's not that's not
the only way to answer the question but
there is a way
that is akin to answering you know what
does it mean to be a horse right but I
guess my point is like with the
definition of species
you can come up with a definition that
contains something really good but you
can't come up with any definition that
you can't do away with pretty easily
right it's a dead human human
um so if we're looking for is the
essence of humans what you know what
makes a human special it ain't contained
in the dead human
um but that's I mean you know maybe you
find this a pedantic
thing then but you know I don't the
question isn't what is it what makes a
human special it says what does it mean
to be human right and so I'm just saying
that one answer is going to be a
phylogenic one and that's not that's not
the question that's being asked but that
is one answer right it is one answer and
we could do 20 others
um and
I don't know I don't know if that's true
so I mean we we could we could walk
through
all of the characters that various which
is for legendary speak for
characteristics but you know the the
characters that various people have said
is the thing that makes us different
right it's language it's tool use it's
War it's empathy it's you know theory of
mind uh it's you know it's tool not just
tool use but tool baking you know all of
which are known in other species so you
know each one of these things has follow
um but then well you know I was just
gonna say Richard ringham famously and
he's not the only one but has you know
really codified uh the hypothesis around
fire making as the thing that basically
catapulted us into fully modern
humanness and
um no as far as we know no one else does
make fire but I would say it's a
pointless definition too
um if you found something else that did
make fire it doesn't change anything
about humans so right um so I I what I'm
actually arguing is that this question
has a particular
status or should have a particular
status of questions that if you decide
that it ought to be answerable
that you effectively take yourself out
of the running to do something useful
right it should be possible to Define
what a human being is I think Heather's
come up with the only definition that
works but it's not useful it doesn't
tell you anything about humans that
matters it would also be true of an
ancestor of humans you know so early
um you know if you're using a
lineage-based answer then the point is
you can come up with something that's so
pre-human that you wouldn't call a human
and yet it's still part of the lineage
um
you can you know have a human born
without a brain and
you know so there's all kinds of
technicalities you get through it and
the real point is look
you have to
kind of mature past this sort of
question you have to realize and you
know we we do this in a couple places
um speciation is a real and important
concept species is not species is a
fraught concept
genetic is an important and real concept
Gene is a fraught and not very useful
concept so totally it's going to be one
of these things where the answer is well
it sort of depends give me the context
for which you want to understand what a
human is and then in some of those
contexts we'll be able to come up with a
definition that's useful but if you well
I mean this question comes with context
then this question comes with context in
which the AI
assessed evaluated a poem written by a
human
and reviewed the tone and message in a
way that the poem writer was taught in
school
now the fact that AI can be taught to do
textual analysis in a similar manner as
high school students can be taught to do
textual analysis actually doesn't
surprise me and that doesn't strike me
as
necessarily
putting us at any risk of feeling like
oh AI is encouraging on humanness
so much of society's decision making is
I mean depending on what the poem was I
guess right it there are some poems that
could be so abstract and so uh deeply
about you know human emotion and
connection that might might make me
rethink that answer but
um
so much of our decision making is
algorithm based true this is to our
detriment at this point too many people
are relying on algorithms and
authorities to make their decisions for
them to you know relying on Hacks
hackers to tell them what to say and how
to say it I mean that's that feels like
a perfect encapsulation but then the
question jumps too so I asked if AI
could replace doctors
uh
AI could replace some some of what
doctors do some of the time
the thing that is getting less and less
done by the medical profession is the
thing that's hardest to do and most
necessary for humans to do which is to
come which is diagnosis which relies on
not just objective lab tests and the
readings from instruments but engaging
the human in front of you and watching
their language their body language as
they talk about this thing rather than
that thing and hopefully going to their
home and seeing them interact with you
know their cat and their son and seeing
what is in their home and smelling
whether or not you there might be you
know a mold problem you know just like
all of these things that an AI can't do
yeah but doctors don't do it
that they could right so there's a
question about you know could AI replace
doctors most of them
um
there's also the issue of even if the
textual analysis textual analysis
um
was completely compelling
right was as good or better as you would
get from the best humans
You Are a Human Being would do this
with the use of Consciousness that might
not be all they're doing right but they
would do it with the use of
Consciousness and what if you could
simulate that with computing power
in other words that the way it was done
was radically different that it would
come up with an answer that you would
take to be meaningful because it was but
that it didn't have an experience of
creating an answer it didn't know that I
had to come up with an answer it just
knew that it had it didn't know anything
it pixeled on the screen right and so
the point is oh is it human nope it's
not
um because no matter how well it
simulates a human
it isn't one yeah right
and that's so embedded in that is you
know awareness of your own self
uh theory of mind
empathy which is one of the things the
AI responded with
uh and intuition intuition being an
interesting one be because some some
large part of intuition is
um keeping decent records on what you've
experienced before such that when you
experience something new you end up
having the right gut feeling about it
but it's actually based on past
experience so that part in AI should be
able to do really well
um but if you're talking about the
um
the amount of material that an adult
human being has actually experienced and
the vast majority of it that has been
almost immediately forgotten
and asking an AI to sort of remember
everything and sort through everything
well we don't have that computing power
right so already there's some kind of
Act of forgetting that is coded into the
AI just like we have coded into US
forgetting that we have no choice about
and the human who has coded what shall
be forgotten that the AI might be taking
in if it had access to every part of a
human experience which we don't have
that yet either would be a different
human consciousness doing that so it
would still be indirectly human yep
that's nice yeah it is good that's not
human at all but it is a people
how's that I don't know we refer to them
as people
do we I do
he's a good person ah but I mean it in
the you know yeah I don't mean uh he's a
homo sapiens no no I just mean he's good
people
yeah he is yeah you wouldn't accept most
people doing that no I really wouldn't
yeah
okay next question
do we need a conceptual update on
Madness in general celebration of mental
illness is problematic yet uh
I don't actually I'm not familiar with
this word s-c-s-a-z it's a name SAS
slash Foucault's critique of the
category as medical remains cogent to me
so I'm not familiar with the first
presumably contemporary of foucaos and
other post-modernists
um so just let me read the question
again surely mispronouncing SAS
do we need a conceptual update on
Madness in general celebration of mental
illness is problematic yet says slash
Foucault's critique of the category as
medical remains cogent to me
so I don't I remember something from the
past about Foucault talking about
Madness but I don't remember I don't
remember what his point was yes I can't
imagine that
um it was very good
he was no dummy no that's true he had
some good points
um
so yeah so
well let's let's leave Foucault aside
yeah
um mental look the human mind is complex
it will fail many many different ways
not everything that is described as
mental illness is mind failure and lots
of stuff that might seem like it you
know if you're sufficiently ahead of
your time you may sound crazy and you
know nobody who thought you were crazy
may be around to realize oh not that
wasn't crazy that was that was real
right
um so anyway there's lots of room for us
to misdiagnose people there are cases of
people having been committed to mental
asylums who simply didn't speak a
language that anybody recognized and so
they were understood to be babbling
incoherently right so this this happens
yep
um but mental disorders are inevitable
lots of mental disorders are Downstream
of novelty we are creating mental
disorders by not realizing that
um simple alterations to our environment
have profound implications for cognition
they have profound implications for
development
and this is relatively easy to prove I
mean it's a Mike mu kind of a point
right what he says about orthodontia is
true
for mental illness in many cases that we
don't have to be creating these
conditions but because we have a dumb
model like well you know
your schizophrenia must be the result of
a bad Gene right right right right nope
sorry development most of the time
but uh
we because we have these bad models we
fail to recognize
what might be done about these things
the fact that psych I mean uh I'm gonna
end up on a rant but
um the fact that psychology is
simultaneously a science and a clinical
practice has been a total disaster
there are lots of things that you can do
for a human being without imagining that
you understand how they function
and so you know the clinical things
should be named differently it should be
practiced by different people yeah
um
and uh
but the you know well
actually I'm not I'm not certain that it
should be practiced by different people
is the conclusion that I agree with well
trade-offs being what they are you would
imagine that if these are really two
different skills that the number of
people who are good at both is going to
be very low but the analogy the obvious
analogy is going to be research and
teaching in a modern University
uh
um a I am unconvinced that in a modern
University these two things have
anything to do with each other and in
fact they are counterproductive
the narrowing of study in becoming a
degreed scientist for example means that
you're probably not very good at
teaching undergraduates the
General perspective because you're so
narrowly focused on some particular
thing
yeah but that that that is about the
rise of the specialist class and
um is a betrayal of what science should
be and all scientists Specialists though
they may be if they cannot pull
themselves back if they cannot change
depth of field and focus enough to say
what does my whole field look like and
how does it look to someone who's never
looked at it before
then they are presumably doing something
very very narrow and they can't see
outside of their own Silo enough to
potentially see big errors that they
themselves are making right but I mean
my my critique is two-part in the modern
context I don't think the people who do
research should be teaching anyway
I just don't think there's anything
about the historical connection between
the two things has been broken
the
corrective would cause you to have
scientists who were good at thinking
and therefore good at conveying how to
think about such problems and so if you
fix this
so that teaching and research would be
sensible together in a way that treating
people and researching what's wrong with
them are not closely related
well now you're talking about psychology
again
I'm saying the parallel between the fact
that
professors teach and research
and the fact that psychologists
psychologize in the lab and treat people
in the office is not a good parallel
that the treat people for
psychological distress for example
is not fundamentally the same skill as
researching the way the human mind works
and that thinking about scientific
processes is the same process as
conveying to others how you think about
scientific processes it is so I'm
surprised to hear you say that
researchers shouldn't be teaching modern
researchers so but again that's about
the problem with modern science right
not about an historical connection
between research and teaching right but
as I understood our argument I was
saying
the psychological profession the
clinical profession should not be the
same thing as the scientific study so I
I think
that they can be
that that can work when I think they
probably should be called something else
rather than just having the you know
adjectival clinical put before
psychologists which most people miss and
they don't recognize that that's a
really different thing
um you know a clinical psychologist and
developmental psychologists are doing
very very different things but
uh requiring the clinical psychologists
study uh other fields non-clinical
fields of psychology in their education
before they go on to become people who
see patients as opposed to do research
strikes me as important if the fields of
psychology know what they're doing yeah
but I think we know that they don't yeah
but again if they know what they're
doing but I don't think even in the
modern era the problem is
the field is too young to be informative
right it's like
um it's like a caveman
should in principle you know know
geologic chemistry in order to Flint nap
and it's like you know you might get to
a point okay but but this is a different
argument then no I think my point is
treating people's
the ill fit between their minds and
their life is a fundamentally different
thing than looking into the human mind
and understanding how it works
and could they eventually converge maybe
but the idea that these two things have
been housed near each other doesn't make
any sense with respect to
thinking scientifically enough to do
research properly and conveying how to
think about science to students those
two things should be the same
where psychology and psychology should
not
well they shouldn't be the same but they
should be closely related
research and teaching let's put it this
way ways of thinking and I would
actually argue you probably get a
benefit you will pay some cost
for saying actually you should be good
at both those things but you will get a
major benefit for saying actually maybe
we make an exemption every now and again
but by and large if you're good at
thinking about this you should be good
at explaining it to others so that they
understand how to think about it no and
this is a point that um that Bob
Trevor's made to us back when we were
undergraduates of his
at UC Santa Cruz Bob Trevor's um you
know one of the greatest living
evolutionary biologists uh with whom we
were lucky enough to to study uh as
undergraduates
um
said when we were thinking about grad
schools that we should really go
someplace uh uh with no
said not when we were looking at grad
schools of grad schools it was about
um museums and Museum having having a
museum because a lot of people would
come through and you get exposed to a
lot of different viewpoints from a lot
of places in the world
um but that with regard to looking for a
position afterwards go someplace where
you'll be regularly exposed to
undergraduates
because they'll throw stuff at you
hopefully not literally that you aren't
expecting these days they will thrust
eventually
um back you know when we were getting
this advice in the early odds
um and in the 90s not so much and then
maybe Dick Alexander also said this and
then maybe it's it's one or both of them
um who said both of these things to us I
guess it wouldn't have been advice
against about the museum but
um you know go someplace where you have
regular interaction with undergraduates
because otherwise you're you're likely
to get concretized like you're just
you're gonna have some view that you
leave grad school with having been in
this sort of wild west world of idea
exchange and if you're only ever seeing
your colleagues interacting
the same people training people who
don't yet know anything necessarily but
are in grad school and you know know
what they think they want to know and
then you go to one conference a year
where you mean the same people who
believe the same things it's much easier
to fall into a rut of I know this thing
I'm an expert the field that I belong to
is awesome and we already know all the
things and let's keep building little
pieces of it as opposed to being exposed
to undergraduates who come in and be
like
I don't get what any of it's about like
why do you believe X and you know the
undergraduate May throw at you something
that goes like oh God yeah the
foundation is rotten how do you know
viruses actually exist right and so you
know that that's that's why we get crazy
sounding questions like that and and
it's going to be easier to snip little
bits of us sounding crazy to the
uninitiated because we
don't simply dismiss it as that's
obviously insane right because there's
almost nothing that's simply obviously
insane
there's some people who are simply
obviously that's true
that's true okay I don't know to what
degree we got that uh
answered that question but uh let's move
on
okay
this question came up a while back and I
would love to answer and I just don't
have an answer but I will ask it I think
I asked it before
maybe I never even said it publicly but
we talked about it
I have been dealing with benzo
withdrawal symptoms and looking for
answers do you know of any research on
benzo's effects on Gaba receptors that
you can point to or researchers names
that come to mind love your podcasts
thank you both
this is just outside of anything that I
have done any any direct research on so
I don't know uh this is the sort of
thing that uh if if there are those in
our audience who do know leaving
comments in the video and um and
uh
hopefully we then see those not because
we go there but someone sorts them for
us and shows us things that we're
supposed to see
um that could be useful although
um
yeah I just I I wish that I had an
answer but I don't
yeah I don't have anything either but
maybe maybe crowdsourcing it will uh
point us to something yeah
okay women tend what time is that women
tend to marry up game theoretically a
lineage that could only be passed down
through the mother would keep advancing
in society
therefore
the risk is being labeled a cabal
this is written in the slightly
slightly telegraphic pathic style of
echo so I'm going to read it again women
tend to marry up game theoretically a
lineage that can only be passed down to
the mother would keep advancing in
society therefore risk being labeled a
cabal
so anything I am confused by the
assertion that women tend to marry up
that can't be generally true
women prioritize marrying up am I right
it can't be generally true well I mean
it's it's a it's a it's a well-known
truism that
um I feel like I've covered my mic there
we go I'm uncovering at Zachary
um
that
I haven't I've lost I've lost the plot
now that uh
following from Trevor's Willard uh that
uh
there are going to be a certain number
of high quality men out there and
um parents who have any control over it
as it turns out parents seem to on in
some species under some conditions uh
will uh knowing that the variance and
reproductive success is much lower in
women than men there will be
many more women of quality X for
whatever character we're talking about
in the middle and men are going to be
more likely to be found
at the ends and so women being more
likely to be in the middle will tend to
be I mean especially in sort of bride
price and you know Dowry polygenous
Society situations
will be sort of offered up to Men of
higher quality
foreign
it just seems to me you know if you have
a monogamous system and people are
pairing off that on average it can't be
true
um well as I said I mean I think I think
we're talking about a polygenous system
um
and I mean we we hear I like I I have
not I've not spent any time with the
research in part because I don't trust
it really because it's going to be
sociological largely
um
but we hear that
with regard to I mean I guess I guess
it's going to vary by character right
like
women are more likely to carry about
care about indicators of wealth and men
are more likely to care about indicators
of of fecundity of beauty and Fitness
and
evolutionary Fitness
so
especially as uh you know women become
more and more educated
there is a smaller pool to choose among
among there would be peers because they
are less likely to marry someone who is
less educated who has less capacity to
earn than a man is
whereas if you're looking at simply
phenotype men are more likely to to
marry up by that characteristic yeah so
maybe maybe that's the problem you're
having with the formulation no I mean
the problem I'm having is solved if it's
Blige in the system and so you can have
multiple women technically marrying up
even though what they are now doing is
dividing a husband so what does marrying
up mean yeah
um
but let's leave that aside and say
if you had a characteristic
that was transmitted through the mother
and the mothers are marrying up
somehow
does it result in what was the
allegation like cabal
well the question is does it result in a
I think the question that is being asked
is does it result in some sort of a sub
lineage that has concentrated some
something or other well I mean maybe
maybe maybe the assumption that you are
objecting to that is implicit here is
that the upness of mate choice is
inherently genetic
and that especially in humans uh many of
the characteristics are going to not
have been directly genetic uh
and so uh it's not going to inherently
be lineage in the same way
yeah I did not take this to be the cabal
question I took not to be
about genes
um and my assumption is that very little
of what marrying up is is about genes
right but I mean the question
specifically assumed that game
theoretically a lineage they'd only be
passed down through the mother would
keep advancing in society that's that
sounds like a genetic well lineage they
can only be passed down through the
mother then is confusing the reason that
I thought that lineage that could only
be passed down through the mother
made sense is that I think we have a
situation like this in killer whales
where you have two distinct uh niches
you have resident killer whales and
transient killer whales
and the babies end up with whatever
Niche their mother had if their mother
is a transient they will be transient
but nothing that is yeah nothing that
I'm aware of
says that the
two subspecies or suppose that
subspecies don't interbreed so in other
words if the males are not doing any
Offspring care which I think they're not
then what is to stop a resident female
killer whale from thinking a transient
male killer whale is sexy
reproducing and then raising a resident
baby male or female right and so the
point is the culture and presume I mean
presumably if if these two sub you know
populations of killer whales exist kind
of side by side you know you know not
exactly sympatrically but maybe actually
even sympathically
they have to be doing that some or else
or else someone would be calling them
different species right they would they
would produce
identifiable characteristics Beyond
culture right so anyway my point is what
is being transmitted there through the
female line is orca culture sure and so
it is a I would argue heritable even
though right uh our colleagues would
argue that that's not heritable because
heritable always means genetic which
they are wrong that's not the right way
to do it but that is the formal
definition now
um but the the point is in that case
females are passing down something that
is heritable or some analog of it
that males cannot pass down
um and I can't quite map on to that what
marrying up
yeah you know there's no yeah yeah yeah
yeah the breeding up
what is breeding you know reading up
presumably exists in orcas but we're not
able to identify it yeah and I mean I
think I think actually
my beginning to untangle it by character
is is right like there is no
certainly there are some individuals who
just don't have anything going for them
and you know and they could be looking
for someone who has something going for
them across all the domains and they've
got nothing but in general that's not
how it is right we're we're mosaics and
uh and given what if we're talking about
well it could be fun to do it in
Arkansas it's like okay what do male
orcas care about in a few well mail
workers are not going to be very choosy
because polygenous because no child care
Etc but uh in monogamous at least
monogamous-ish species like humans
what the males
actually care about and what they say
they care about is going to be a pretty
good match and similarly what the
females care about what they say they
care about pretty much for each other
but those two things are not going to be
exactly the same at all
well as between males and females you've
got the character issue that you're
talking about
within males and females I would argue
you don't really need to
think on a per character basis that
there should be pretty good agreement
between females of a species or between
males of a species what the desirable
potential mates are there should be a
ranking and there will be some noise
I think it depends on it it's going to
depend on environment you know if if if
you are
uh
a homesteader who's trying to make a
living in a place where no one has tried
to make a living before I'm not but go
on
you might be looking for a different
kind of mate than if you are in
Manhattan in the 1980s totally get it uh
I will take it back and I will say
for a given
temporal spatial location yeah
there should be pretty good agreement
within asex for the hierarchy of
potential mates but comparing
into male individuals to female
individuals with regard to like breeding
all right I mean we do do this I'm
remembering I think we've made reference
to it before but that great line from
that oh that terrible terrible City you
could do this better than I can
um the uh if I may create this painfully
brilliant
joke for you Andy Dick
is remarking that he and a colleague the
colleague comes into the lunchroom
and says something to the effect of
did you hear that uh
Larry and Cindy got together and Andy
Dick rolls his eyes and says oh they
could both do better
it's a brilliant joke so that's that
that's
obviously we have it in our heads that
uh that there's up and up and not so
much up yeah and there's not total
agreement about uh about what's what all
right uh somehow even though we didn't
start with very many questions we are
running out of time let's get through a
few more
I propose
we change the term lab coat wearing
scientists
to lab coats wearing scientists
scientists oh
lab coats wearing scientists oh wow
suddenly that's devastating that's great
I like lab coats wearing scientists lab
coats wearings that's wonderful yeah
I now imagine the lab coats themselves
becoming animate it's a little scary but
I don't think it's any scarier than the
lab coats wearing scientists that's good
it's pretty darn good I like well well
played well done yeah
um what are your thoughts about Chile's
death rate among jabbed children and the
mainstream media silence on it
I don't know anything about it
first I've heard about it I don't know
anything about it I do not know anything
about it either okay
I must tell you when I started to hear
you read the question I assumed this was
about the restaurant but well that's
actually how it's spelled here oh
there's they are I mean actually I don't
actually I don't know how the restaurant
is spelled but it's not spelled like the
country and this is not spelled like the
country so maybe this is spelled a Third
Way
um but can you read the question again
now that I know that we're talking about
I'm assuming that this that this is
about the country you know that long
thin ones happening oh I know I know the
country
yeah
what are your thoughts about I'll
pronounce it I'll pronounce it we should
stop laughing because it's not a very
funny question it's not at all what are
your thoughts about Chile's death rate
among jabbed children and the mainstream
silence on it
yeah I mean we can pretty much infer the
story but I don't think we should
because uh the hazard of it is too great
but yeah
um you know there's an awful lot of
Silence about what seemed to be patterns
maybe chile has data that uh Chile has
data maybe chili's tested
foreign
the wrong question to be giddy over but
um no I'm yes it is and we don't know
anything about it so like we're not
going to provide any analysis here yeah
so but I would be interested to know
about it if there's if it does if it
reveals anything yeah
uh there's actually only four more
questions we're gonna try to get through
them and if someone comes in with
another one maybe we'll get to it but
um
I don't know what this means
what's a TW one twitched by Discord
because you don't read ahead compassion
for your censorship Gauntlet review that
question into today's light question
mark
okay yeah I don't I'm sorry I can't
follow sorry man I don't I think it's a
guy I don't I don't know what we use one
twitched by Discord because you don't
read ahead compassion for your
censorship Gauntlet review that question
into today's light question mark I feel
like
you took like several uh crossword
puzzle clues and put them together
I feel like you took mushrooms and it
didn't share them which case cool good
for you
um yeah I just we don't know sorry it
sounds like you're trying to convey
something and I don't need to make light
of it no obviously we're just at the end
of our
seriousness for the day or something but
but we can't we don't know what it means
um
oh
can you discuss your understanding of
the argument by some that viruses don't
exist
not really but we already did that also
we said you don't have to talk about
that the trip okay yep uh really one
more come one comment and one more
question uh so is there I'll just I'll
do the call the comment
first and then the question that's where
we'll end for today uh the comment is
just thank you and take heart your
voices of Sanity have helped so many of
us
thank you yeah that is that is very
meaningful and we do hear that from
people and we are so grateful because
it can be hard especially given now that
we've moved to a place where we run into
fewer people uh it can be hard
to remember when the insanity continues
seemingly unabated
and with new kinds of force as in
Brett Weinstein Ben Shapiro and also Ben
Shapiro are voices some vaccine
misinformation and conservatives also
yeah
also that
um except the two bench pairs are
actually conservatives but you're not
okay final question
final question is there any value
whatsoever in cryptozoology
which is I believe the study of things
like Sasquatch and Yeti and the loctus
monster and what else
to some people it's going to be viruses
um well no viruses aren't animals so
that's not cryptozoology crypto biology
something well look we do discover
creatures that are unknown periodically
often that's not that interesting
because it's some creature that we
thought you know we thought a frog it
turns out ultimately some frog turns out
to be two different species and we
didn't realize it that happens all the
time and the the old Maps the Explorers
Maps the European explorers Maps or
before I actually don't know my history
my cartography history well enough to
know like when did sort of there be
dragons show up
um sort of over the edge of the world
right uh
I'm guessing that some early seafarers
saw some creatures from the deep that
really did exist and it got instantiated
as dragons and encoded on maps that that
wasn't entirely a we're just guessing
that there's probably that's where the
dragons are going to be right no I I've
always taken it to be
um there's some cool stuff over there
and I would rather you didn't see it so
that I could
position myself oh it's the Waldron
island effect it's the Walden island
effect we're just gonna need an
explanation here so um off the northern
there's not really a tip but the
northern edge of Orcas Island and the
archipelago that we live in now so orcas
San Juan Lopez and Shaw are the four
major
uh fairy served islands and then there's
guemes which is very served by a
different ferry system
um but those are the the big islands
that you can get to with a regularly
scheduled boat
there are a bunch of other islands that
have people living on them that there's
no regularly scheduled boat Waldron is
one of them
Aldrin is the farthest north in the
American side of the uh
of the archipelago
and its residence its inhabitants are
not all that wild about newcomers
discovering their Island and
adventuring there or moving there and so
they put up a website in which they
described the island for anybody who was
curious and they mentioned the fact that
there had been a Penitentiary with a
prison break in which not all the
inmates had ever been found that there
was a lot of poisonous snakes epidemic
of rattlesnakes that it's a desert
island it's really not much surface
water right they described a hell on
Earth kind of a scenario deeply
improbable if you've ever been to this
part of the world at all on every count
and in fact completely untrue right they
did not say there'd be dragons because
presumably people now see through that
trick yeah but so you think that there
be dragons was a century centuries ago
version of what the the the kind-hearted
if somewhat isolationist inhabitants of
Waldron Island uh put up on that website
yay so many years ago yep right no no
totally totally yes however
cryptozoology
any benefit
well it depends what it means if
cryptozoology is like looking for the
Loch Ness monster and and Bigfoot
um and who else
all the bigfoots really yeah Sasquatch
big I guess that's question the same
time right
Bigfoot and Sasquatch are the same thing
the yeti actually there is some
paleontological evidence for something
there's some teeth
of uh gigantopithecus is it oh yeah
um
so anyway I don't know what that story
is but presumably not
coated in white fur I mean maybe wearing
furs
there's some creature that put out teeth
that we can't match the creature to the
teeth yeah um so I don't know what that
is but
um is there any value in it it's
probably a waste of time but um you know
there are creatures out there that have
never been seen and every so often you
know in the deepest jungles of Vietnam I
think there was a was it a small
what was it a small bovid was recent not
recently ten years ago it's a little bit
of a servant yeah some kind of unglit
yeah I don't think it was a servant but
um
anyway I don't remember but people do
occasionally find things that we don't
know anything about and the question is
what's the opportunity cost of looking
for really
um unlikely fines if it can sort of
organize
drive you to experience the natural
world right like
I don't know I've not looked into the
passion that some people here in the
Pacific Northwest have for Sasquatch
I had at least one student at Evergreen
whose father was an avid Sasquatch
I don't even know what the word is
enthusiastic Aficionado yes and she
reported the student reported that as a
child
some of her best times in life were
going out on these extended camping
trips with her dad and yes her dad was
driven by a search for Sasquatch and no
he never found Sasquatch but it enabled
him to develop an amazing relationship
with his daughter that might not have
happened otherwise so you know there if
if you know like like passions that
aren't
like passions of All Sorts that may not
produce more beauty or truth in the
world but which help you sort of
organize your world your frame so that
you are driven to discover other things
and make connections with other people
cool it's better than sitting around
watching useless television yeah snipe
Hunter
um so I would also say that there are
people I mean this is an extension of
your point but there are people let's
say
all postmodernists we would be better
off if they would take up they were
cryptozoology cryptozoologists which
would allow them to be good to the
people that they love by
um leaving them alone going outside
going outside yeah yeah eating
freeze-dried food and uh
well that's the three yeah if you go to
the ones that you love but yeah okay you
did it
not very well but no no no uh so you
heard it here first Brett thinks the
postmodernist should become
cryptozoologists so that they like you
he missed the queue I was yeah I don't
know what
the post-modernists should become
EXO cryptozoologists
Astro cryptozoologist yes yeah yeah
quickly
immediately immediately yeah um
and that will help them yes as you
should do too yes and Zachary should Now
read the writing on the wall as we
advise that in two weeks we'll be back
and until then
be good to the ones you love
eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
needs a second
or more than one maybe we should become
cryptozoologists
[Music]